I I do believe in doctors I know there's
there's a yes there's a new movement out
there now that people have the internet
that I think I might know a little more
than the people but then they've also
[__] with the trust of the People by
putting out all kinds of insane [__]
drugs getting their people in on the FDA
and clearing [__] that shouldn't be
cleared
uh and getting people hooked on [__]
[__] no it isn't that's what I always
find amazing when it's you know when
they they the you know when that was in
in style which I think it's over now
when they were they were going after
stand-up comedians in there you know
that can you believe they said this joke
it's just like is that worse than
working at a drug company and
infiltrating the FDA and giving people
drugs children drugs that are you know
are gonna [__] them up in the future but
you want that yeah today yeah and then
us we're like what's the deal with trans
people and everyone's like ew even
though I've never done it I didn't like
that that was gay are you [__] hate
gay people no I don't I never said
anything I know yeah